[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
على المشي ، يجب أن يرسل الدماغ أمرًا إلى
منطقة رمز المفتاح
المسؤول عن التحكم في الحركات
عندما تكون هذه إصابة في الحبل الشوكي ، تم
قطع هذا الاتصال ،
كانت فكرتنا هي إعادة إنشاء هذا
الاتصال بجسر رقمي مثل
الاتصال الإلكتروني بين
الدماغ ومنطقة الحبل الشوكي
التي لا تزال سليمة والتي يمكنها التحكم في
ساق كاتم الصوت
[الموسيقى]
قبل بضعة أشهر ، لذلك كنت أريد أن
أقوم بوقوف رائع مع أصدقائي بعد مرور 10 سنوات.
حياتي اليومية ، لذلك أنا سعيد جدًا لأنني أستطيع
مشاركة قصتي
[الموسيقى]
شكرًا لك
[تصفيق]
نقوم بإجراء عمليتين جراحيتين مختلفتين ، هناك
عملية جراحية واحدة على مستوى الدماغ نقوم بإجراء عمليتين
صغيرتين لحجر القحف لوضع أقطاب كهربائية
لتسجيل إشارة الدماغ
وجراحة أخرى على مستوى
الحبل الشوكي حيث نضع أقطابًا كهربائية
أعلى الحبل الشوكي في المكان
المسؤول عن حركة الساق
[موسيقى].